Über Corona reden heißt:
Streit. Offenbar.
Auch unter diesem Video
werden sich Leute streiten,
verbal prügeln,
weil's ein Video über Corona ist.
Fast schon unabhängig davon,
was ich hier sage.
Ich weiß nicht, wie's euch geht,
aber ich bin's leid.
Immer diese Teams, diese Lager:
wir gegen die.
Persönliche Angriffe
statt sachlicher Auseinandersetzung.
Jo mei, willkommen im Internet.
Nein, nein, nein!
Es ist schlimmer als sonst.
Man merkt, dass wir
seit 'nem Jahr in 'ner Krise sind,
die alle belastet.
Es ist nicht deswegen frustrierend,
weil ich mir wünschte,
dass wir uns alle lieb haben
und auf unseren Balkonen singen.
Sondern weil viele dieser Debatten
unsere Zeit verschwenden.
Zeit, die wir in lösungsorientierte
Debatten stecken könnten.
Denn es werden oft
Konflikte herbeigestritten,
die so gar nicht da sind.
Oft gibt es zwei Lager, zwischen
denen ein tiefer Graben liegt.
Heute will ich versuchen zu zeigen,
dass dieser Graben
vielleicht gar nicht einmal
so tief ist,
wie uns Diskussionen auf Twitter,
in YouTube-Kommentaren
oder in TV-Talkshows glauben lassen.
Lasst uns ein bisschen entspannen,
holt euch 'nen Tee.
Es folgt ein unaufgeregter,
sachlicher Versöhnungsversuch.
(Abwartende Musik)
Manche Meinungen sind einfach extrem.
Zum Beispiel, wenn man denkt,
dass Corona nur inszeniert ist.
Aber ich will mich hier
auf die Mehrheit konzentrieren,
die die Realität dieser Krise teilt.
Sich aber nicht einig darüber ist,
wie man diese Krise am besten angeht.
Fangen wir mit den Konflikt
Gesundheit, Wirtschaft an.
Darüber wird ja seit dem ersten
Lockdown im Frühjahr 2020 debattiert.
Kurze Side-Note: Die Wirtschaft
sind natürlich wir alle.
Es sind große Konzerne
mit all ihren kleinen Arbeitnehmern.
Es sind kleine Unternehmer,
Selbstständige.
Nicht alle können sich leisten,
'ne Zeit lang
keinen Umsatz zu machen.
Wenn 'ne Restaurantbesitzerin
ihren Laden schließen muss,
ist es das Ende
einer Existenzgrundlage.
Einer Lebensgrundlage.
Wie wägte man Menschenleben gegen
Lebensgrundlagen von Menschen ab?
Das ist ein schwieriges Dilemma.
Nur dass wir uns in Wirklichkeit
gar nicht für eins von beiden
entscheiden müssen.
Es ist ein falsches Dilemma.
Und Bildung, Kultur, Familien
und Psyche und so weiter.
Lasst uns Folgendes versuchen:
Lasst uns mit den Dingen anfangen,
die wir in unserer Gesellschaft
mehrheitlich ähnlich sehen.
Und uns Schritt für Schritt
dem nähern,
wo die Meinungen auseinandergehen.
Letztes Frühjahr, als die Bilder
von Bergamo durch die Medien gingen,
waren wir uns mehrheitlich einig,
das wir das bei uns
nicht sehen wollen.
Dieser Konsens
besteht bestimmt immer noch.
Und zwar nicht nur
aus gesundheitlichen Gründen.
Stellen wir uns das vor.
Spätestens, wenn's auf
den Intensivstationen eng wird ...
Side-Note: Hier geht's
nicht nur um Betten.
Auch wenn das Personal am Limit ist.
Dass nicht mehr
alle Intensivpatienten
ordentlich behandelt werden können,
von Unfallopfern über Herzinfarkte
bis zu Corona-Patienten,
wird auch die Wirtschaft gelähmt.
Selbst wenn Merkel
und die Ministerpräsidenten
dann sagen würden:
Genug Lockdown,
alles bleibt offen, genießt es.
Dann wären die Restaurants,
Konzerthallen und Fußballstadien
trotzdem ziemlich leer,
weil viele Menschen aus Eigenschutz
zu Hause bleiben würden.
Davon abgesehen schaden
Ausfälle durch Krankheit oder Tod
auch der Wirtschaft.
Auch wenn man Corona-Todeszahlen
und Wirtschaftswachstum
verschiedener Länder vergleicht,
sieht man keinen Konflikt
zwischen Gesundheit und Wirtschaft,
sondern das Gegenteil.
Es ist unser gemeinsames Interesse,
gesundheitlich und wirtschaftlich
die Kontrolle
über das Virus zu behalten.
Wo wir uns auch einig sind:
Lockdowns sind (Zensurton).
Auf Dauer schadet das
nicht nur der Wirtschaft,
sondern auch der Gesundheit,
konkret der psychischen.
Es ist unser gemeinsames Interesse,
wirtschaftlich und gesundheitlich
Lockdowns möglichst kurz zu halten
oder ganz zu vermeiden.
Wenn wir uns dann noch
drauf einigen können,
dass ein ständiges On-Off,
also Öffnen, Schließen,
anstrengender und frustrierender ist,
als eine langfristige stabile Lage
und dass nicht nur uns unsre Psyche,
sondern auch die Wirtschaft
Planungssicherheit
und Stabilität braucht,
dann sind wir uns
in vielen Dingen schon mal einig.
Der Streit dreht sich
nur noch um die Frage:
Wie bleiben wir, in diesem
gar nicht mal so großen Fenster
zwischen Kontrolle über
das Virus verlieren und Lockdown,
und das möglichst stabil,
bis zum Ende der Pandemie?
Lockdowns stinken.
So weit waren wir ja schon.
Natürlich wollen alle
so schnell öffnen wie möglich.
Die Frage ist nur:
Was ist möglich?
Denn wenn wir jetzt
die Kontrolle verlieren,
in 'ne dritte Welle und
den dritten Lockdown reinrutschen,
dann stinkt das noch mehr.
Da sind wir uns bestimmt einig.
Aber in dieser Diskussion,
sind die Öffnungen
zu schnell oder zu langsam,
geht eine Sache unter:
Selbst wenn wir es schaffen würden,
so schnell wie möglich zu lockern,
aber nur so stark,
dass wir die Kontrolle behalten
und bis zum Ende der Pandemie
nicht noch einmal zumachen müssen,
dann klingt das zunächst
ideal für die Wirtschaft,
ist es aber gar nicht automatisch.
Gehen wir zurück ins Frühjahr 2020
zum ersten Lockdown.
Da gab's bereits diese Studie
vom Institut für
Wirtschaftsforschung, ifo,
und dem Helmholtz-Zentrum
für Infektionsforschung, HZI.
Also eine gemeinsame Studie
von Wirtschaftswissenschaftlern,
Infektionsforschern
und Epidemiologen.
Ausgehend vom 20. April,
wo die ersten Lockerungen anfingen,
berechneten die Forscher
unterschiedliche Szenarien
vom Verschärfen
der Lockdown-Maßnahmen
bis zur maximalen Lockerung.
Ich fand's spannend,
noch mal zurückzuschauen.
Einerseits ist heute
einiges anders als letztes Jahr.
Wir stehen
in vielen Dingen besser da.
Wir können viel mehr testen,
besser Kontakte verfolgen.
Wir wissen mehr über das Virus, etwa,
dass es einen Sommereffekt gibt.
Dann wird die Lage verschärft
durch die britische Mutante.
Der R-Wert dieser Mutante
liegt gerade über eins.
Heißt, die dritte Welle
rollt im Untergrund schon an.
Man schätzt, dass sich diese Mutante
im März durchsetzen wird.
Doch qualitativ ist diese Studie vom
letzten Lockdown immer noch relevant.
Denn die Kosten,
die für die Wirtschaft entstehen,
fallen U-förmig aus.
Sowohl sehr strengen
als auch sehr lockere Maßnahmen
haben höhere Kosten
für die Wirtschaft als mittelstrenge.
Die Strenge bezieht sich hier
auf den R-Wert.
Das eine Extrem
ist ein R-Wert von 0,1.
Das andere Extrem ist R gleich eins.
Also man senkt die Fallzahlen nicht,
sondern balanciert
genau auf der Grenze.
Aber wenn man hier
nicht die Kontrolle verliert,
warum gilt nicht einfach:
Je lockerer,
desto besser für die Wirtschaft?
Na ja, kurzfristig gilt das schon.
In den ersten Wochen bis Monaten
ist alles straight forward.
Also, je höher der R-Wert,
desto höher die Wirtschaftsleistung.
Je kleiner der R-Wert, desto größer
der Schlag für die Wirtschaft,
aber dafür kann sie sich
schneller wieder erholen,
und das R-gleich-eins-Szenario
auf Dauer überholen.
Wenn wir und dann noch klarmachen,
dass R gleich 0,1
wirklich nur
ein hypothetisches Szenario ist,
das gar nicht zur Debatte steht,
in Deutschland war
der Sieben-Tage-R-Wert
nie unter 0,6,
dann ist das schlechteste Szenario
für die Wirtschaft,
also das teuerste,
das mit der
schnellstmöglichen Lockerung.
Und das, wie gesagt,
unter der Annahme,
dass man es schaff, bis zum Ende der
Pandemie die Kontrolle zu behalten
und nicht noch mal schließen muss.
Wenn man das noch mal machen muss,
ist es noch teurer.
Es ist das teuerste Szenario
und auch das zermürbendste,
weil man immer on edge balanciert
und nie richtig aufatmen kann.
Wenn wir uns jetzt anschauen,
was seit Herbst bei uns los war,
sehen wir, dass wir genau dieses
zermürbende Szenario gelebt haben.
Wir sind deshalb an einem Punkt,
wo wir uns zumindest
in einer Sache einige sind:
So geht es nicht weiter.
Also, die No-Covid-Strategie ist ja
ein großes Streitthema momentan.
Ich persönlich bin nicht ganz sicher,
was ich momentan
von No-Covid halten soll.
Letzten Sommer waren wir
verdammt nah dran an diesem Ideal.
Eigentlich hätten wir im Herbst,
als es wieder losging,
No-Covid verfolgen sollen.
Hätte, hätte, Fahrradkette.
Es wäre verhältnismäßig easy gewesen.
Wir hatten niedrige Infektionszahlen,
hatten Kraft getankt über den Sommer.
Aber jetzt sind alle müde und
ausgelaugt, es ist anstrengender.
Dass man darüber diskutiert,
ob No-Covid die beste Strategie ist,
ist nur wichtig und richtig.
Was mich aber nervt, ist,
dass viele der Streits über No-Covid
unsre Zeit verschwenden, weil sie
auf Missverständnissen beruhen.
Zum Beispiel denken manchem offenbar,
dass Ziel von No-Covid sei es,
SARS-CoV-2 auszurotten.
Wenn das so wäre,
wär das natürlich Quatsch.
In Wirklichkeit geht's nur darum,
das Infektionsgeschehen
lokal möglichst stark einzudämmen,
um anschließend dort
möglichst viele Freiheiten zu haben.
Bestenfalls wird man
zu 'ner Grünen Zone,
in der sämtliche Beschränkungen
fallen.
In der Videobeschreibung gibt's
Details zur No-Covid-Strategie
wie auch zu Kritik und Gegenposition.
Auf dieser Basis könnt und sollt
ihr euch eure Meinung bilden.
In meinen Augen ...
ist No-Covid deswegen sinnvoll,
weil selbst wenn es
nicht realistisch ist,
insofern, dass man es in Europa nicht
schafft, Grüne Zonen einzurichten,
wäre es gut,
da möglichst nah ranzukommen.
Aber das ist meine Meinung,
die man nicht teilen muss.
Die vielleicht ich auch noch
ändern oder anpassen werde.
Mich frustriert es, dass wir
momentan nicht debattieren können,
ohne uns direkt
komplett zu zerfleischen,
obwohl wir so viele
gemeinsame Interessen haben.
Ich liebe Debatten. Eigentlich.
Ich bin Wissenschaftlerin.
Debatte is my love language.
Aber so emotional, so hitzköpfig,
so feindselig
wie momentan diskutiert wird ...
Manchmal glaub ich, allein deswegen
könnte No-Covid nicht funktionieren,
weil die Strategie voraussetzt,
dass wir alle an Bord sind.
Ich meine, wir sind alle an Bord.
Wir sitzen alle im selben Boot,
zwangsläufig.
Ob wir's wollen oder nicht.
Nur ist es ein Gummiboot,
und die Luft ist ein bisschen raus,
fürchte ich.
Ein Krankenpfleger
auf der Intensivstation,
der schon vor Corona
überarbeitet war.
Weil Intensivstationen schon
seit jeher unterbesetzt sind.
Er wird's weniger prickelnd finden,
wenn Hendrik Streeck sagt,
man müsse noch genauer erforschen,
wann das Gesundheitssystem
wirklich an seine Grenzen stößt,
um zu schauen,
wie viel Luft tatsächlich ist.
Eine alleinerziehende Mutter, die
schon vorher kurz vor Burn-out stand,
jetzt auch noch homeschoolen muss,
wird die Krise kriegen,
wenn Christian Drosten sagt,
man müsse bei den Schulöffnungen
sehr vorsichtig sein.
Die eine ausgebrannte Mutter
wird nur erleichtert sein,
wenn die Schulen wieder aufmachen.
Die andere wird sich Sorgen machen,
dass das Kind die Familie
anstecken könnte.
Jemand, der einen geliebten Menschen
an COVID-19 verloren hat,
wird eher Angst vor Öffnungen haben.
Jemand, der mit
'ner Depression kämpft,
wird eher Angst
vor einem längeren Lockdown haben.
Es ist doch völlig klar,
dass jeder von uns mit seiner
ganz persönlichen Realität kämpft.
Nicht nur, dass wir durch Twitter,
YouTube-Kommentare,
Fernseh-Talkshows vergessen,
dass viele von uns
in großen Teilen dasselbe wollen.
Sondern auch,
dass wir das Verständnis
für die Bereiche verlieren,
wo unsere Meinungen ganz
selbstverständlich auseinandergehen.
Wo's auch nicht nötig ist, dass wir
uns auf eine Meinung einigen.
Sondern, dass wir einander zuhören
und versuchen, uns zu verstehen.
Wir müssen deswegen
besser darin werden,
weil wir nur gemeinsam
diese Krise durchstehen können.
Es geht nicht nur darum,
was Politiker sagen.
Es geht ganz besonders darum,
wie jeder Einzelne von uns
sich verhält.
Ohne ein gemeinsames Verständnis
dafür, dass wir ...
gemeinsam in diesem Boot sitzen,
werden wir auch gemeinsam alle
schlechter rauskommen,
als wenn wir uns zusammenraufen.
Selbst Karl Lauterbach
und Hansi Flick
konnten ein spannendes
und konstruktives Gespräch
mit gegenseitiger
Wertschätzung führen.
Warum können wir das nicht alle?
Wobei ich nicht denke,
dass man jeden Streit beilegen muss.
Nein, wir müssen
um die beste Lösung ringen.
Wir sollten nicht weniger streiten,
sondern besser.
Konstruktiver, lösungsorientierter.
Und nicht unsre Zeit
mit unnötigen Debatten verschwenden.
Zeit, die wir brauchen,
vor allem jetzt im Wettlauf
gegen die neuen Virusmutanten.
Wir wissen: wenn zwei sich streiten,
freut sich der Dritte.
Der Dritte ist nun mal
dieses (Zensurton) Virus.
Warum können wir
unsere Wut nicht gemeinsam
gegen dieses (Zensurton)
Viru- ... (Zensurton)
Falls ihr das aktuelle Debattenklima
auch leid seid
und ihr findet,
dass dieses Video etwas geholfen hat,
teilt es bitte.
Fall's ihr's nicht findet,
teilt es bitte nicht.
(lacht:) Ernsthaft.
Ich will nicht
Teil des Problems sein.
Danke, dass ihr
bis hierhin geschaut habt.
Hier ist ein Video von "psychologeek"
übers Verliebtsein.
Vielleicht hilft das.
Wir sehen uns in zwei Wochen.
Bleibt sicher!